aiuto in vista del congo ha beccato un
paio di volte
benvenuti soliti astori soldi nuova
avventura sempre ma sta già iniziando
c'è scritto per il 13 che è un giorno
che porta sfortuna mi ha praticamente
assisteremo uno spettacolo di magia
lo spettacolo sta per iniziare sediamoci
siamo seduti qua questa è una nuova
storia
paurosa rob lowe ed è uno spettacolo di
magia ma sospettano tanti colpi di scena
quindi mettete di nuovo di voi avete
qualcosa da bere qualcosa da mangiare
lasciate un bel mi piace e iniziamo la
c'è qualcuno che sta correndo e questo è
arrivato in ritardo
guarda e toby automi ciao
eri e sedersi con noi toby
il ritardatario seduto ok è arrivato
proprio giusto in tempo sta per premiare
quindi
eccolo lui il mago
il mio nome è harry è programmato farò
qualche scherzetto questa sera ok altro
trucchetto
siete tutti pronti
non vedo l'ora di vederli che ne pensate
di qualche fuoco d'artificio ad ora in
pochi bull ma ha colpito qualcuno
che
con la luna gigante
per ora non sai niente di paura no
neanche di magico
bellissimo dico io per il prossimo
trucchetto avrò bisogno di un volontario
forse tu e ha chiamato uno ha chiamato
il giocatore quello che andrà secondo me
non sia andato cosa gli farà poverino
adesso vai in quella scatola
ok
ma un po paura lui
bene adesso ti farò sparire nel vero
senso della parola guardate tutti quanti
lo spoilerino totali ho fatto è un mago
il vostro amico è stato tratte
trasportato guardate nell'altra no ma
non c'è di anche qua sarò tutto
il nostro amico non è più lì
inizia delle cose strana rende chiedendo
la porta ma non funziona sembra che non
abbia funzionato o no e quelli dove è
finito poverino avevi ragione rick renga
carlino e facci poi tornare il nostro
amico indietro da noi oppure a ttt
affronteremo
cattivo calmatevi calmatevi stavo solo
scherzando
come questo ma questo il vostro amico e
proprio in mezzo
in quella stanza
[Musica]
scusi sa fa il mago nessun problema
c'è ancora qualcosa di strano con questo
mago non mi convince ok adesso avrò
bisogno di un altro volontario non ci
penso nemmeno non mi chiamare 9
chiamarmi chiamare
[Applauso]
il caffè
the stories tv ha fatto apposta ho
cliccato niente adesso vieni qui dove
sono in piedi o in piedi ma hai mai
voluto volare no grazie il bonus è così
credo proprio di si sa
bene oggi ce la faranno o no aspetta
davvero visito
chiedermi spara in aria
stai volando telefonando è un po
avranno una sala rallentato bellissimo
vero non è una pagina a basiano
[Risate]
fermarti certo
vediamo se cadi adesso notti fa si sta
facendo girare avete presente girare
aspetta un attimino
adesso un sistema
aiuto
aiutatemi forma torino non ti
preoccupare è tutto sotto controllo
ha affermato barbatano lo farò
non ti preoccupare di testa visse
e operò no siete materie realizzata di
the stories dove è andata a vita stories
o no tu cosa cosa vedi
lo stesso portale allora siamo si
sentono e non posto bruttissimo
teletrasportare in un altro posto che
possono stuffer inquietante ci sono
tanti occhi rossi che mi guardano a
becco ti sei tornata o meno male
ha funzionato 6 ritornata come vi ho
detto prima
tutto è sotto controllo aiuto non fate i
suoi toccati perché se non finirete
18 trani adesso puoi tornare al tuo
posto e questo non era il mio posto
perché mese quindi io spero che vi state
divertendo in questo show in questo
spettacolo quindi ho un ancora un ultimo
trucchetto da farvi vedere mai già fatto
due trucchetti noi non ti preoccupare
questo è l'ultimo ma il più grande ora
chiama vitale
no no no no no
tutto bene
se rotto il mago dopo così tanti anni
[Musica]
posso finalmente finire il mio
spettacolo
anche se non è questo il modo in cui
volevo finire oggi
cosa vuole fare
otterrò la mia rivincita su questa città
la mia band è la mia vendetta scusate il
pe rosso
sei mesi inizia detto
sono quelli ragazzi
non era una buona idea venire qui oppure
la vendita su questa città che cosa gli
ha fatto questa città forse l'hanno
preso in giro non andate su soli hanno
tirato le uova
dieci ore prima dello show lo so devo
dire che dobbiamo cercare di salvare
un cane quadrato qui mai visto guarda
c'è un akita ma un marito lo sa ma
dobbiamo sbrigarci giorno
berlino 6 pro berlino e gli occhi
celesti
ricche in ritardo lo vedi
ciao marley nomi qui pollino si può
anche prendere
se ci sono dei soldi qui berlino ha
trovato dei soldi presidente flora il
pop finché rumeni eric ok
paparella e io posso prendere berlino
forse no a buy e vado anche io ora c'è
scritto che c'è una persona che è
scomparsa e ma carter davvero l'avrà
presa il mago ricordiamoci questo nome
perché sicuramente si saranno svalutati
in questa storia di rob lowe ma carter
si è vero che sta arrivando a goccia
pistoletto dobbiamo salvarci prima dello
spettacolo per epico possiamo andare a
di giorno ecco è arrivato qualcuno
questo ricco ciao ragazzi ieri che sono
un po in ritardo che cosa è successo
rick dico io non riuscivo a dormire bene
perché avevo ero così felice vedere lo
spettacolo di oggi ed ecco perché sono
arrivato un po in ritardo ok non fa
niente ok beh allora sbrighiamoci
accesso ma noi non dobbiamo andare allo
spettacolo quindi oggi guarderemo un
film operoso nella foresta faretta si è
venerdì 13 quindi e non c'è niente di
più pauroso che guardare un film nella
foresta venerdì 13
ma prima di tutto dobbiamo preparare
tutto e cosa dobbiamo fare dobbiamo
comprare un po di cose da monitorare
e andiamo al supermercato andiamo al
supermercato si se lui ama seguire c'è
qualcosa di strano se persone che
sono scomparse nomi postero ovunque c'è
qualcosa di strano sta succedendo
qualcosa credo che sia stato il voto
haring ci possiamo proteggere gli uni
con gli altri come non lo so una
bestemmia morixe andiamo superman fatto
che cosa possiamo comprare
ma questo quadro m cassiere
svegliamo signore sta dormendo
si
è svegliato scusate mi stavo giusto
riposando un pochino diventato tutto
così noioso da quando robin è sparito
poverino quindi il rubin è il ragazzo
del poster per sì sì lui lavorava qua
con me senza il suo aiuto
il negozio è un po disordinato ordine
quindi questo è un po difficile trovare
queste cose che voi stiate cercando
ok quindi tutti quanti ascoltatemi ho
una lista di cose ok dobbiamo trovarle
tutte quante qui va bene uniamo le
nostre forze con la mela fiabole quindi
io abbiamo più il
blocco piccola cosa credo che siano
tematica bibite
allora facciano fagioli
ah ecco
queste sono nascoste in
una chiave sia stato fa ci ha provato la
sto prendendo prendo comunque da
mangiare
altro cioccolata dai trovale coca cola
prima che scada inter e come sono le
dovevo la ecco la trovata non trovata
una ecco l'hanno trovata tavoletta
volare trovato 7 molto bene ho il mio
prezzo 5.000 adesso trovate la
cioccolata civiltà né legge la
produzione a vendola pure qui
ma non vogliamo far cadere questa
mattina quando pensi allora cioccolato
saranno l'altra con un'altra ma della
carta igienica ce ne sarà ancora
completato e adesso cosa dobbiamo
trovare e ci potevi pure aiutare però eh
si io sto pagando per tutto sto facendo
la mia parte quindi è tutto dice il
cassiere
solo una domanda dove state andando oggi
ragazzi ma saremo nella foresta a
guardare dei film allora vi suggerisco
di comprare queste mazza da baseball
magari non sapete mai cosa potrebbe
essere vedere un gay certo le prendiamo
andiamo ci serviranno per difendersi dal
mago harry per come è passata bene dai
quando si parte dobbiamo ancora fare
un'altra cosa comprare la pezza
tuttora ma tutto bazzurri somiglia molto
a vitale andiamo andiamo la pizzeria è
d'accordo ovviamente
ecco cena in pizzeria a me entrare
dalla porta
buongiorno signor anche l'ente
addormento
vorremmo ordinare della pizza
finalmente qualche cliente
ciao e benvenuti alla mia pizzeria
sembra che noi siamo i primi clienti
no in realtà c'è anche un ragazzo da
quella parte lui che primo cliente
quindi qui non volete quindi vorremmo
due pizze a ho capito qualcos'altro no è
tutto ma scusa ma se noi siamo in cinque
perché dovevo prendere due piccioni 19
56 per due cose lo faccio io a pizza
adesso ok risponde rick ricca ha
comprato solo due figlie e più costano
pure 50 dollari ragazzi ho speso tutto
il
il resto delle dei miei soldi a comprare
quelle mazza da baseball possiamo fare
qualcosa per avere quelle pizze quindi
non avete soldi no
adesso ci mette a lavare i piatti beh mi
faccia qualcosa che cade da fare e fare
come potete vedere il ristorante un
pochettino in disordine pulitelo per me
evitano le due pizze ok va bene
allora dobbiamo ripulire il ristorante
per avere la vita
ma con i racconti che pure il nostro
intento è preparato per terra mi ha
buttato
maleducati che ci sono poniamo puliamo
una buccia di banana
ok pulire pulire pulire e tivan giri
questa in realtà il mago nerini ma lo
sai che forse lo è solamente fatta ok
ora a darci le pizze schiaccia la pizza
ceoban e un lavoro perfetto ecco la
pizza come promesso ma grazie è tornato
quando avrete sempre la pizza guarda
sono la pizza
al trancio noi poveri ha detto tornate
quando volete però con i soldi pronti ad
andare nella foresta cento sul mare allo
spettacolo il mago capi venerdì 13 alle
quattro di pomeriggio che era lo
spettacolo a mezzanotte insieme qui otto
ore prima
dell'ora ce l'abbiamo fatta ma adesso
possono andare nella foresta rick dico
io cosa sta succedendo da quella parte
come ho detto non ho soldi
ma topi so che rai dei soldi dice un
bullo non mentire dobbiamo aiutarlo tipo
perino giusto dice eric andiamo lì
presto ei due stop lasciatelo in pace e
allora viene a fermarci non c'è problema
prendiamo la matta dobbiamo utilizzare
la nostra mazza da baseball ragazzi wow
ma quindi proprio bazar e la vita
proprio
a loro non si ritengono più ma sono
immobile
facilissimo finora questa zona
ok forse siamo riusciti a salvare il
nostro amico pochi gli abbiamo
spaventati marilyn abbiamo spaventate se
ne stanno andando
torneremo e ora potete dare la foresta
da ieri hanno finalmente mi hanno
lasciato in pace grazie perché quei due
si stavano infastidendo sono due ragazzi
tramite della mia scuola e mi minacciano
sempre ogni giorno comunque il mio nome
e toby e io sono ricche e questi sono i
miei amici è così bello vedervi
incontrarvi tutti continuiamo a cercare
qualche indizio si è che indizio cosa
sta succedendo la ragazza che nel poster
che è scomparsa non è ma carta e mia
sorella
poverino
ecco la fish che lui sta andando in
libreria a cercare qualche indizio per
ritrovarla eirik dovremo aiutarlo dico
io
aiutiamolo quindi possiamo andare grazie
lo apprezzo molto dice toby nessun
problema andiamo in libreria allora
brevi e dobbiamo cercare concessi o
presto silenzio questa è una libreria
ora libraio e non abbiamo detto niente
vabbè vabbè si legga testa cerchiamo
qualche indizio troviamo un libro di
persone scomparse
no ovviamente entra il mago anche una
domanda visto che lui si stava facendo
sparire sarà proprio stato lui break
contro abbiamo tutti un altro motoria
non la dobbiamo controllarle tutte vanno
tutti al trono del libro che guardiamo a
mo vediamo che cosa è successo in
passato guarda questo è rimasto nel vago
un bambino di 13 anni è scomparso nel 99
sembra interessante sparite in una
foresta vicino qua vicino è proprio il
malgoverno che stiamo andando a spetta a
noi stiamo andando proprio quel posto
sto dicendo io a guardare un film
spariremo anche noi ragazzi dovete
comunque andare nella foresta abbiamo
tutto abbiamo preparato tutto dovete
stare molto attenti perché mia sorella è
sparita proprio in quel posto ma non
posso non facendoli stanno facendo un
picnic con il suo amico robin robinho
non anche il marito ora diventando
sempre più strano che satoria
continuiamo meno mandare il libro di 13
sempre sta cercando personale 9 manca
poco allo spettacolo in quel che manca è
ore e ore allo show abbiamo passato un
sacco di tempo cercando le dixie si
trascinano dentro l'area mia sorella
guarda qui c'è qualcosa che auguriamo
buona fortuna ad obi grazie dice lui
cosa è quello dopo la parte è un
volantino in cui si è scritto
lo show magico grati 13 a mezzanotte
nella navetta è proprio lo show dr uno
show nel a fare uno show magico nella
foresta si sono poster da tutte le parti
perché vuole proprio rimaniamo ho una
teoria se questo show magico o se
collegato alle persone che sono
scomparse un punto interessante ma non
vi preoccupate di me
ma cercherò un'altra volta ok proviamo a
trovare il posto sabato 14 alle 12
quindi che dopo lo sbraco allo
spettacolo 10 minuti dieci minuti dopo
lo spettacolo eccoci siamo ancora qua
voi ragazzi potete rimanere avere a che
fare con i primi nostri io
ho quindi ci ha lasciato qui con i suoi
amici mostriciattoli beh proviamo a
sconfiggerli con le mappe o no questo
non va bene toby andiamo in città è
vaccinato attenta una cattolica dobbiamo
fermare harry ok a
voi due ragazzi dovete rimanere qui e
per mare ai mostri o chi dico io ma come
perche io sono d'accordo
vengono a mangiare la p esatto ecco i
due mostri dobbiamo fare del nostro
meglio dici tu prova a non morire ok che
ci provo però inevitabile che questi qua
già mi hanno preso
aiuto
dai dai che ce la facciamo
il brano delle ombre e si ma che mi sono
dei dissennatori come si chiamano quelli
di viene rivolta
noi ci siamo quasi
tutto ok manca un altro
uno a testa brava torre a farsene
arriveranno altri stai attento amici
ecco un'altra opzione peraltro con
natale o no sono importava na li
dobbiamo bloccare il portale in qualche
modo e se gli diamo la pizza
dobbiamo scappare trovare league
abbiamo i due bulli ma forse erano loro
almeno ha smesso di piovere ok è
comunque dove sono topi eric i mostri
arriveranno presto sì siamo di nuovo
lì abbiamo trovato 15 stavano seguendo
e adesso abbiamo anche noi delle mazze
da baseball
un altro combattimento
guardate che non dobbiamo per forza da
combattere bene anche
vedere una vita cosa sono quelli è
esatto potrete infatti fate bene a
scappare quei due bulli no non possono
essere reali e invece si
dimentica di quelli che abbiamo detto
questo la mia mamma ebbene sembra che i
mostri ci abbiano raggiunto
che cos'è io abbiamo
di nuovo team beckett e la mazzata
sembra che i miei mostri non erano
abbastanza dove sono ricche topico 68 di
loro 18 minopoli o catturati e presto
diventeranno dei miei mossi ecco dove
sono riprese scomparse non te lo
permetteremo gli dico io tappa a ride
lui potete provarci ma no a
scomparire dobbiamo affrontare molto
vicina ma noi sappiamo che
dobbiamo affrontare lui credo guarda le
boe che questa mazzata dobbiamo
affrontare non casca sempre questo che
ha fatto data attenta state sa tirando
degli spuntoni
attenta non beccare gli ispettori forse
dobbiamo sconfiggere i vostri non
capiscano oro rimanderebbe ai mostri
sconfitta che ci sta si sta pronti tutti
i modi a beccarci
no non riesco a prendermi però lui non
li facciamo niente se non lavoriamo
dobbiamo cercare di scappare da lui ecco
la partita adesso la passione
meno male che io sto
ko che ora devi solo scappare finché non
si carica va bene noi possiamo forza
spero di nuovo a mese nero con questi
spuntoni
[Musica]
toni stime rilasciate mi piace per
portarsi e partono dai
è difficilissimo chirivì via
[Musica]
certo in due non è facile
meglio in due che da sola e si
[Musica]
sente tutto rispetto
meno male abbiamo ancora un po di vita
quanto c'è che 51 ok io 46
fuffa da e ricaricati harry
eccomi qui quindi sempre allo stesso
punto
[Musica]
ha un sacco di vita ho paura che non ce
la farei credo che sia il time di essere
che sia il tempo di essere più veloci
o no è diventato ancora più veloce
marchesi e petina ma così forse si dovrà
caricare più in fretta solo sto
aiutano vista meccanico
attento io ho beccato un paio di volte
abbiamo pochissimo a vita
no mi sta tutta
[Musica]
ma è così ancora una volta ce lo siamo
tornati
quindi in mente di riuscire a
sconfiggerli ci stiamo provando
volta di latente
tirato fuori di nuovo gli spuntoni
è ancora più veloce di prima non sapete
nemmeno che cosa sono a chi cota ho
affrontato io
sono stato escluso da tutti
problematiche tra di riprendere con noi
trovati dai dati già 3 ago
sono stato giudicato per niente è più
calma che sono qui
sono stato lasciato morire è addirittura
a chi
dai fattori
fermati
non avete idea di come si sa che cosa
nessuno può saperlo
no no no no no no non si sta mettendo
male molto male molto male non fa male
molto male
aiuto la mia vita dal 10 per cento no
vieni qua dietro veri è arrivato 6 5 4
dopo
qualsiasi morto ma dietro sembra che non
ci prenda forse c'è mancato poco tutti i
miei poteri a la mecca miglioramento
ridacci i nostri amici indietro free ma
mai già ormai dobbiamo combattere ancora
non abbiamo scelta cosa
aspetta ma è tornato cosa che cosa è
successo di cionet i nostri amici vero
nome in un posto buio e terry e qua eh
si non vi preoccupate è stato sconfitto
mi farò
adesso puoi spiegarci che cosa stavi
cercando di dire perché stavo cercando
di catturare
[Musica]
nel 1999 ho trovato un libro nella
foresta
non era un libro normale
un libro che parlava di magia nera e
siccome ero un bambino e ho sempre
voluto essere un mago con quel libro
poteva imparare dei trucchetti che
nessuno aveva mai fatto prima era la mia
occasione di diventare un mago di
successo e seguire il mio sogno ha per
tutti piacevano i miei trucchetti e
stavo diventando famoso in questa città
ha quasi tutti c'era qualcuno della mia
scuola che ha poi non piaceva e pensava
che fosse una persona pericolosa con i
miei poteri che i miei poteri fossero
pericolosi quindi mi hanno bollato ogni
giorno a scuola poverino ma un giorno
hanno deciso di andare oltre al cono mi
hanno invitato nella foresta per
mostrare i miei trucchetti a loro ma non
non hanno smesso di di infortunarmi
finché non sono riuscito a fare un buono
buono spettacolo mi hanno lasciato in un
buco in una foresta a morire è diventata
la super tragico questa sì ma come
potete vedere sono di longo
meno male questo è perché ho provato un
incantesimo proibito dal mio libro è
comunque l'incantesimo improvvisamente
sono arrivato in un posto molto oscuro
dove ho passato il resto dei miei giorni
non so come ma sono riuscito a tornare
indietro e dopo così tanti anni sono qua
che cerco vendetta ma francesi sono
riuscito quindi stai pianificando di
trasformarci ancora i mostri per per
avere la tua rivincita e li aspetta un
minuto da quei mostri che abbiamo visto
prima e la mia sorella e robin dobbiamo
salvarli anche loro ascolta r lo
sappiamo che non è stato facile per
cercare vendetta è solo una cosa che ti
farà star è ancora peggio è passato un
sacco di tempo e si è riuscito ad andare
avanti possiamo essere tuoi amici ad
aiutarti dai servizio solo sarà uno dei
tuoi incantesimi no
hai ragione ma ma comunque grazie lo
stesso quindi a finisce qua no che fa
ieri lo stesso che stavano cercando di
aiutarti il libro e deve essere
distrutto bene meglio così altrimenti
trasformerà altre persone i vostri io
devo andare dove il paio dando ho
apprezzato molto le vostre parole per
limitare aprile per me esatto è anche
per il libro ti darò la tua sorella
indietro fino al bene il problema è
anche robin poverini
giornata
che cosa è successo dice ma ho visto
mago nella foresta e quindi sono sono
spari per un posto oscuro troppo fumoso
e ri è sparito nel frattempo è una lunga
storia magari harry potrebbe spiegarvela
ma non c'è più non è un altro che
atterri a bevaio mangio
se con giro a pizarro e della vita no
farlo prima continuo a non capire dice
robin è lo capirai presto ma per adesso
prendiamoci una pausa
[Musica]
il gioco
abbiamo compreso la grande madre
state scriveteci nei commenti un voto da
1 a 10 a questa storia del mago e poi è
uscita la seconda parte le semi facciamo
la seconda parte ed alzate un bel mi
piace e se questo video raggiunge il 5
milioni anche se faremo anche la seconda
facile e ora mi lascia un po a pattern
caselli eletto quindi care per vedere
inoltre altri mercato su quella che
preferite
ciao